federal election september 20th there's
a bunch of stuff to cover it seems like
one of the biggest topics that's getting
a ton of uh
conversation on anyway is this
kovid beer bug
passports vaccine passports
and
the stand that all these political
parties seem to have on it because
as far as i can tell by
looking at um trudeau versus his
colleagues should we call them
colleagues as friends
you know when they're in court you watch
those movies when they're in court and
they say well my friend over here
i guess you know his you know his
friends don't really uh stand out and
say much aside from nodding their head
and agreeing to it um interesting thing
happened today on ontario premier doug
ford
uh who was vehemently opposed
to vaccine passports uh announced today
at one o'clock that there's vaccine
passports and a few days earlier trudeau
bribed each of the provinces i believe
with a billion dollars to implement
vaccine passports so
it's an interesting environment man um i
don't talk too much about politics on my
channel i have
been involved in politics uh for about
there's a stint for about 16 to 18
months about 10 years ago
maybe i'll talk a little bit about this
on the cast
assuming max does or doesn't make it but
i was doing some lobbying on this uh
bill in parliament called bill 55 which
was um going to completely change the
rules on the uh debt business to help
people get out of credit card debt so i
spent quite a bit of time talking to
all of these politicians
and i know jack meets saying well
um i spent quite a bit of time with him
because he was the um critic on the bill
so i'll definitely talk to you guys a
little bit about that with my experience
with uh politicians and um what i think
of them and uh you know the selection
and voting patterns and what's going on
another interesting thing that's come up
as well
uh because of this
vaccine passport that they just
announced
you're not going to be allowed to vote
in person after a certain date i think
it's the 13th if i'm not mistaken
and that means you're gonna have to use
mail-in ballots
and we saw what happened with mail-in
ballots to our friends south of the
border
right
so
history seems to be repeating itself
it's you know it's convenient that uh
trudeau announces and starts to
encourage and bribes the provinces with
vaccine passports
um right around the time of the election
and then makes it difficult for people
to vote in person
resulting in mail-in ballots if you
don't have two jabs you can only vote in
person apparently if you have two jobs
now
so
you want to cast a vote you want to have
your voice heard do it before the 13th
you can vote early from what i
understand
um let's grab the super chat over here
from robert how's the best way to stop
this vaccine passport business killer
there's
a lot of businesses that are
still going to from what i've heard okay
and i've heard quite a lot there's
there's some private facebook groups now
coming up
but i understand with uh
six figures worth of of people in there
that are
either business owners or patrons and
they're basically saying we're not going
to discriminate we don't care if you've
been pinned or not you know if you want
to be our customer we're happy to serve
you
um so i think there's going to be a lot
of businesses out there
and patrons even that are not going to
um
roll with this
it's supposed to be a temporary measure
you know this is going to go away sort
of thing
let me grab the
the party comparison charts because um
i was going to use this but i was told i
was only going to have his ear for about
15 to 20 minutes so
i figured i would uh
just kind of
converse with him directly on his
platform items that he wanted to discuss
let's do this
i take an objective approach to this
because it's just
people get so you know bent out of shape
um
with some chart base here
compare on these issues
there's
there's a lot of problems that's
happening right now i can tell you right
now with the mainstream media
because
according to the polls
uh
max bernie's party is
got about six percent
in the polls which is about the same as
a green party but he gets no mention
in a lot of these publications um
like cbc news and stuff like that
mclean's magazine which is a canadian
publication
um talking about their their platforms
and their position and even the stock
photography they don't even use the
stock photography they're just using the
main parties uh or who they deem to be
the main parties even though he's pretty
much neck and neck or surpassed the
green party green party still gets
mentioned the block quebecois gets
mentioned but
there's very little or
muted mention of what it is that um
he's he's talking about so
i mean i wish him the best you know he's
he's tearing it up across the country he
was he was arrested a few months back i
think it was about a month and a half
back in winnipeg because um he was
basically on the road and wanted to have
some conversations and
you know rally about what he was all
about and uh because they had the
strictest um
was it
masked mandates and social distancing
mandates they actually arrested him
and put him in cuffs and i think he
spent eight hours in jail
and for
who could potentially be the prime
minister of canada it's an interesting
way to deal with the situation
given the circumstances in which he's
approaching it
you can go look for the video online you
know if you want to see it uh prow says
they're using a boiling the fog strategy
with the box pass first not essential
biz then on to retail stores and finally
grocery they'll later expand the
definition of fully backed to three plus
the problem with the um
the whole
vac stuff and ryan if you want to hop in
um i sent you the link already you can
hop in now because i'm not sure if or
when he's going to show up or 16 minutes
past the hour and they said he was gonna
be here around seven so i'm assuming
he's he either can't make it his
schedule is too tight or whatever it
doesn't matter
um
but i mean
the interesting thing about these
booster shot things is
canadians
ryan's a fellow canadian so i thought
it'd be prudent to have him on here with
this
is um it doesn't end at one shot two
shots or triple shots they're going to
keep basically pumping out these shots
to
keep you on the subscription basis of
immunization or what's supposed to be
immunization anyway
but um
yeah this
this is the first step to a fully
segregated society
something which is
i've never seen in my entire life to be
honest with you i'm close to 50 i've
never seen anything like this
this is um
you know they put they put gold stars on
people in the 1940s in a country in
europe
and you know it started with that
you know the
depending on what the color your skin
was you weren't allowed to drink out of
certain water fountains or sit on
certain places on a bus at one time in
history this is not that much different
it's not that much different i don't
know that it's gonna get to the grocery
store you know situation
is it i don't know you know they're
gonna stop you from buying food
i guess i'm gonna have to go out hunting
for my food maybe i don't know there's
gonna be a lot of people out there
you